[Music]
first up for the cover piece this week
Jonathan Spire takes a look at the new
world order as the violence continues in
the Middle East and Ukraine are we
beginning to see America's World Order
crumble and Iran Le politics making
gains Jonathan joins me now alongside
former US defense secretary Richard H
Jonathan and Richard thanks for joining
me Jonathan you are currently based in
Israel can you give us an
update yes it's not a I mean obviously
the main event of the last 24 hours has
been the visit of President Joe Biden
but in terms of the broad
situation uh there are still 300,000
Israeli reservists mobilized they are in
their great majority currently waiting
on the border with Gaza there is still
uh air action Israeli air action over
Gaza and something which I think has not
been sufficiently noted in global
coverage uh is that the situation in the
north on Israel's border with Lebanon is
also extremely tense there have been
several launches today of anti-tank
missiles by the Lebanese hisbah
organization at positions of the Israel
Defense Forces one of them in a place
called Shah uh there were a number of
people a number of service people
wounded so the situation to the north uh
is also extremely tense so I think those
are the main points I would raise just
in terms of an immediate updates
Jonathan thank you for that update you
write the cover piece for this week's
magazine about the New World Order
suggesting that history is moving Iran's
way can you talk us through
it well my sense uh as someone who's
been looking at the region living in the
region covering the region now for quite
a few years is that the main beneficiary
of a number of historic events underway
in the Middle East over the last decade
and a half to two decades has been the
Islamic Republic of Iran specifically
the breakdown or fragmentation or even
partial collapse of governance in a
whole number of arabic speaking states
of of quite long historic standing and
specifically I would point to Lebanon
Syria Iraq and to some degree Yemen also
where go Central governance has to some
degree broken down and the Iranian
practice the IRC Islamic revolutionary
guards calls methodology and practice of
irregular warfare namely the
construction of or support for uh
political slm military organizations in
neighboring countries has proven to be a
remarkably useful uh method for the
implanting of political power and
influence in those uh collapsed spaces
so the loss uh of the Palestinian
Authority of control of the Gaza Strip
in 2007 and its loss to the Hamas
organization is a local variant of a
process which is visible across the
region and which has in its total
brought to the Islamic Republic of Iran
a previously unprecedented level I would
say of influence and power across broad
spaces uh in the region and the current
I would say events regarding Gaza are a
product of that process in the sense
that regardless of whether Iran sort of
pulled the trigger or was in control
tactically of the events of October 7th
which we don't know and probably will
never know the Kamas military capacity
and ability comes from and only from the
relationship with Islamic Republic of
Iran based on the uh Broad order
Regional strategy which I just tried to
outline Richard as a former Defense
secretary what do you make of Jonathan's
comments there do you think that history
is headed Iran's way and is America
still the global policeman of the
world there's lots in there I don't
think America ever was quote unquote the
global policeman of the world uh even at
the height of its uh influence there
were many things going on the world that
the United States was not in a position
to to to control but clearly we're
living in a world of a more distributed
power uh and the United States has uh
experienced shall we say quite a few
setbacks in the Middle East obviously uh
most apparently in Iraq and also the
United States now is somewhat more
focused Elsewhere on Europe and on
what's now called the uh indopacific in
terms of the region itself I think what
Jonathan laid out is is true in the
sense that Iran has increased its
influence significantly uh across the
region from from Yemen through Iraq and
Syria to Lebanon at the same time Iran
can't be happy with the Abraham Accords
uh with the the growth of acceptance of
the reality of Israel in the region Iran
has also suffered all sorts of internal
political and economic uh
difficulties in in in recent years and
what was about to happen uh
interestingly enough was a a
breakthrough between Israel and Saudi
Arabia and a certain uh United States
and Iran entering into a kind of modus
Fendi that has all blown up by events of
the last 10 days or so so we'll now see
how this uh we'll see how this plays out
but suddenly there's there's much more
uncertainty uh and unfortunately much of
it is negative and it's easier to see
how this war widens and how more
problems come to the Middle East then
somehow this is a uh an unlikely waste
Station to to progress Richard you wrote
in foreign affairs that you think
Washington should try to restrain
military action in Gaza what practically
speaking would that look like I think it
looks like what President Joe Biden is
saying and doing in Israel what he's
doing is balancing support for Israel
and it's right to do certain things but
essentially saying even though you have
the right to do certain things even
though your emotions are telling you to
do those things you might want to think
twice or three times before for doing
them so the United States has clearly
pushed back against the quote unquote
Siege of Gaza Gaza the cutting off of
water and fuel electricity and so forth
the United States has already pushed
back against that and clearly the United
States is counseling restraint and if I
had to summarize the American policy
it's go after Hamas but don't go after
Gaza basically choose something that's
much more uh Discerning in what you do
so rather than go big going small
whether it's from the air or from the
ground and my my guess is that will be
closer to what ultimately happens that I
think there's a lot of Israelis who also
have fundamental doubts about the wisdom
of going ahead with a large ground
operation all the cost all the
international outcry the possibility it
would lead to war widening and then at
the end of it it's not clear again how
you establish political Authority in in
Gaza Israel Israel saw that in 200 five
and it's not at all obvious to most
observers that if they went in big now
and then left they would have a lot to
show for it Jonathan what do you make of
Joe Biden and America's handling of the
current crisis yeah I think what uh the
administration is trying to do and I I
agree with Richard on this is to both uh
support Israel but also to try to uh
restrain uh I think that the the
dispatching of the two or the aircraft
carrier USS Gerald Ford and now Dwight D
eisenh her is heading there as well well
the USS Dwight the eisenh her is is
deeply significant and this is I think
clearly an attempt to say to Iran and
hisbah you know as the president himself
has said well don't get involved um
placing Iran and hisb in before quite a
dilemma in a certain sense because
they've been talking in recent years now
for what they call the unification of
the Arenas or unification of the fronts
which is supposed to represent this
notion of a kind of United group of
islamist uh paramilitary movements
behind Iran under Iran's leadership
directed against Israel and if Israel
now does go into Gaza in a major way and
Iran then does not intervene they will
look somewhat weakened in a middle
eastern context having not sort of
backed up a great deal of rhetoric in
recent years at the same time with the
USS General Ford the generald Ford there
in the Mediterranean Iran would be
exercising taking the real chance of uh
tussling with you know United States
military response so that will place
them in a dilemma as well I agree I
think the administration doesn't appears
to be seeking to avoid a major operation
on the ground the government of Israel
we should be clear has stated as its
goal the removal of Hamas political
Authority in uh Gaza it took a few days
to say that for a while it was sort of
not quite clear in different ministers
saying different things it has now said
it at the top levels H if that is indeed
the the serious intention of the
government of Israel it's very difficult
to see how that could be carried out
other than by a major ground operation I
agree also that it's not at all clear
because Israel has not made it at all
clear what would replace Hamas governing
Authority in Gaza that's something which
the government of Israel I think more or
less on the record said well we don't
know we're not we've not given that
sufficient thought yet which is not
necessarily uh you know which is not
clarifying either so that's a goal if
Israel wants that it will have to carry
out an operation on the ground and I
tend to agree that the Americans and
others appear to be counseling against
that I guess we're going to find out out
in the days ahead what will take place
you can't keep 360,000 uh people
permanently mobilized right that's how
many reservists Israel has has mobilized
you can't keep them in in uniform you
know indefinitely so something has to
move and has to happen uh fairly close
in the fairly close future I would say
Richard you said on Twitter that
President Biden's speech from Israel was
quote nothing less than masterful others
have been more critical especially about
his use of of the phrase other team when
he basically used the word team others
have suggested it wasn't the most
thoughtful phrase I'm I'm curious as to
uh what has one over your praise for
that speech What specifically do you
think he's getting
right people can focus on little things
like his use of the word team but the
the overall thrust of the speech I
thought tried to threat a needle on one
hand he's trying to I think rightly and
understandably support Israel in the
wake of these Savage attacks and Israel
has the right and as he's often said the
duty to respond terrorism cannot be
allowed to be conducted with impunity
that's it on the other hand he is trying
to essentially councel Israel he's
trying to temper its rage and he wants
them to go in a much more refined sort
of way again as I said before to focus
on Hamas not not Gaza and that's a
difficult balance uh he's got a lot of
popularity in Israel he's banked a lot
of good we from his earlier speech and
from American Aid and and so forth and I
think so far at least he's pulling off
this very difficult balancing trick it's
speech was both filled with personal
Reflections also had a lot of
substantive policy he announced uh the
aid humanitarian Aid package for for the
people of Gaza so it's interesting that
the policy here is quite subtle and
whereas some of the rhetoric is more
shall we say uh quote unquote Pro Israel
but the actual substance of what he's
he's doing I think is is is quite uh
measured and I don't think he would
disagree with a lot of what Jonathan and
I have been saying about the the doubts
about the wisdom of going in llarge this
idea of eradicating Hamas I just don't
think it's physically doable or
politically doable with military
instruments and even if somehow you were
able to capture a lot of their
leadership the next day something like
it would fill the political vacuum it's
not like the Palestinian Authority or
Arab governments are ready to to step in
so I think I think what ultimately if we
can somehow contain this crisis we're
probably GNA have to deal with a Hamas
with a Hamas controlled Gaza for some
time to come and then the question is
will Israel and others find a way to
moderate hamas's Behavior not because
Hamas has changed but through
deterrence Jonathan the Abraham and
courts were mentioned briefly at the
start of our conversation is anything
left of the Arab and Israeli repr
approachment oh very much so I mean I
think first of all it's important to be
aware that none of the countries which
which signed on to the Abraham court and
most significantly of course United Arab
Emirates have pulled out as a result of
the events of the last 11 days and I
don't expect that that will happen very
much not so so the general Trend with
regard to that historic process is still
there in a certain sense the events of
the last days don't in any way push
against the dynamic of the abrahamic
cours because in many ways the abrahamic
cours were
specifically a notion of bringing
together countries opposed jointly
opposed to precisely the kind of
politics and the kind of uh of military
uh Behavior if I can put it that way
represented since October 7th that's to
say United Arab Emirates famously is
most U primarily worried deeply worried
about the Muslim Brotherhood and about
Sunni islamism across the region Hamas
is a manifestation of prec prely that
style of politics so October 7th and
what's happened since doesn't in any way
negate the logic of the abrahamic cult
in many ways on the contrary it
precisely strengthens at least the
security and defense element of the
Abraham Accords which was a very very
significant underlying uh factor and in
this sense you know I agree that of
course the roson hoped for with with
Kingdom of Saudi Arabia will now not be
happening along the same timeline but
the logic of close connection between
Israel and Saudi Arabia is reinforced I
would say by the events of the recent of
recent days can I just say also with
regard to the issue of Hamas and
removing its Authority you're absolutely
right of course that as a political
movement it's not possible to destroy a
political movement or a political Trend
using military power governing
authorities of course can be destroyed
using military power on the ground and
history is replat with examples of that
so in this sense you know the doability
of the goal Israel has said itself is
there you can do it if you're prepared
to expend sufficient amount of energy
and money and lives on the task ask as
to whether Israel will indeed undertake
that stated now stated goal in today's
head sure we don't know but you know
there is a coherence to the desire to
destroy Kamas political Authority if you
want to pay the price for it what is not
yet coherent in the Israeli case is that
the government has simply not related to
what should and would come next and
that's surely a question that must uh
must be asked Richard what do he make of
that well again um the biggest problem
is what would come next and even if some
how you could root out Hamas again I'm
not sure that's possible because it's as
much of an idea and an ideology and a
network and a movement and the mere
process of rooting them out in some ways
would create more converts but the
larger point is true and there's the
problem after 2005 a political vacuum
would be there I don't see anyone from
the outside ready and able to fill it
the Palestinian Authority can't even
really govern the West Bank how is it
going to govern uh Gaza the Arab world
really wants no no part of it the quote
unquote International Community lacks
the capacity and and uh and the will and
the consensus to do it so again I just
don't see it as a as a serious
short-term alternative in the long run
I'd love to see Hamas marginalized but I
think that's going to require a whole
different political track to the
Palestinian issue and basically show the
Palestinians who are willing to rule out
force and live with Israel compromised
to reach some kind of a coexistence
that they will accomplish much more by
going down that path than hamash will by
rejection and violence but that's
something that will take years or
decades uh to work out and that's
something that could only begin once the
dust settles here Richard you've
predicted before a new era of disorder
due to the muting of us dominance but
critics might say that it was the US
overmars in the first place what would
you make of
that look the United States did
overreach in certain cases clearly in
Iraq and to some extent in in
Afghanistan but the idea that uh the
United States is responsible in large
part for disorder in the world is
preposterous that's just ideology I'm
not sure if it's coming from the far
left the far right or or or both I think
historians will be critical of what the
United States has done over the last 30
years uh when it came out from the cold
war with tremendous opportunities and I
don't think in some ways we've made good
on that uh on those opportunities but in
many cases for what we haven't done
rather than for what we've done and
there's no way you can attribute uh Mr
Putin's uh violent war against Ukraine
to what the United States has done or
now what Hamas has done or you know the
rise of Chinese power is simply a
function of of Chinese society and
economic uh growth the world deserves a
lot of blame for what hasn't been done
on global issues like climate change so
again this this criticism of the United
States I think says a lot more about
those doing the criticizing than it does
about historical reality and Jonathan
just to finish uh back to your cover
piece on that New World Order how much
of that world order can be attributed to
the Changes in Attitude in places like
America but really across the West when
it comes to militarization and the
appetite for these countries to get
involved in other
conflicts yes I think that that is a
very notable
Factor that's to say if we thinking of
the Middle East at least you know the
sense of a declining willingness of the
West and of the United States in
particular to to respond to security
threats if we think for example of the
attack on Saudi Arabia and oil
processing facilities by the Iranians
through a proxy in September 2019 you
know as one example of the sense that
countries in the region have had of a a
declining willingness of America and
that but yeah I think that processes can
be to that I think for example the
Abraham Accords in some ways was a
coming together of countries
traditionally aligned with the United
States who jointly had become aware that
the United States itself didn't want any
more involvement Inland and Upstream in
the Middle East so to speak and that
therefore were required to make their
own sort of uh uh you know links to one
another I do think that's right I would
say also um with regard to what's taking
place in in Gaza just now that when we
talk about various this not not quite in
terms of the question you asked but just
in terms of the earlier discussion I
think it's important for us to note when
we talk about Alternatives that October
7th was also a result of a failure of an
existing policy and that policy was the
attempt to seek to coexist with uh
continued Hamas rule in Gaza so whilst
undoubtedly as we've been discussing
there are major difficulties associated
with any project of replacing Hamas in
Gaza it is also the case as we've seen
so graphically demonstrated over the
last 12 days that coexisting with Hamas
Authority in Gaza May well be an
impossibility if at least we wish as
indeed we of course do wish to provide
security for the residents of of
Israel's South so I think that's
something which didn't quite come up in
the discussion which I wanted also just
to uh to put out there Jonathan and
Richard thanks so much for joining
[Music]
me